infiniti war est un film réellement
incroyable et je suis justement en train
de bosser sur un gros trois théories le
concernant mais le temps de vous faire
patienter je souhaitais vous parler de
quelque chose auparavant
étant donné que les mystères sont au
rendez vous pour ce combat ultime crâne
rouge est de retour dans une finition
noire et bon sang qu'est ce qu'il fout
ici
ce dernier était le méchant est l'ennemi
juré de captain america the first
avenger
mais il abusa énormément du pouvoir du
tesseract pour créer des armes et
devenir plus puissant ce dernier le
punissant le tesseract étant un portail
il était évident qu'un jour ou l'autre
crâne rouge fasse son retour
et oui il n'était pas mort ce dernier a
donc finalement atterri sur la planète
de vol mire où il est devenu le gardien
de la pierre de l'âme il explique tout
compte fait apte à nocé gamme aura que
sa présence sur vos lumières et comme
une sorte de punition
le dessert est le jugeant indigne
l'aurait envoyé au fin fond de l'espace
afin de garder la pierre de l'âme
missions imposées qu'il effectua pendant
plus de soixante dix ans avant que
thanos n'arrive la récupérer une
punition très dur car crâne rouge devant
le gardien d'un pouvoir réellement
puissants qu'il pourrait convoiter mais
que jamais il ne pourra posséder
sacrifier une âme pour une âme soit
celle d'un être cher mais pourquoi
réintroduire red skull comme ceci
peut-être certainement pour confirmer
son retour ce dernier n'est plus qu'une
sorte de fantôme gardien et surtout
danos à récupérer la pierre de l'âme et
red skull est liée à cette dernière
il est peut être possible que ce dernier
puisse maintenant mourir après avoir
guidé thanos avait récupéré n'étant plus
prisonnier en tant que gardien mais je
pencherais plutôt pour une autre idée
red skull est donc lié à la pierre de
l'âme il se pourrait que ce dernier soit
donc toujours dans cette dernière à
l'accompagner
comment le prouver avec la présence de
gamme aura comme petite fille à la fin
du film
cette dernière semble être prisonnière
de la pierre de l'âme et donc pas
réellement morte
il se pourrait donc même que toutes les
victimes de tano soit enfermé dans cette
dernière est donc pourquoi pas red skull
ce dernier en était le gardien et
peut-être même que crâne rouge et dans
la pierre de l'âme à cause du gant de
l'infini clan thanos claque à des doigts
exactement comme gamme aura d'ailleurs
crâne rouge et maintenant joué par ross
marque end et non hugo weaving rajeunir
l'acteur pourrait être un moyen de le
faire revenir dans avengers 4 hugo ne
voulait plus jouer dans marvel et c'est
donc le célèbre acteur de walking dead
qui prit sa place
et en plus il a adoré son rôle et est
fan de marvel donc l'avenir semblerait
être propice pour ross dans l'univers
marvel
mais même s'il souhaiterait absolument
rejouer son rôle marvel reste très
secret pour le moment en tout cas il
serait piloté par marvel de faire mourir
red skull dans l'ombre alors qu'il est
l'un des grands ennemis du mc eu
bref à vous de me dire merci à ceux qui
laisseront un pouce bleus et qui
partageront la vidéo cet argot rock et
que le line up soit avec vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]